what do you say to the to the man who is
just kind of confused on like like what
does it mean to be a man today and you
know there's it's like I don't want to I
don't want to be you know like just
gender roles and a woman don't want me
to be too strong and you know there's a
lot of like talking and a lot of like
battle of the sexes stuff what what
would you say to that guy who's like
like like I don't I don't know how to
show up cuz like I feel like anything I
do is just gonna like piss women off and
so there's well you said something very
good there that that's important to say
the battle of the sexes is really the
the root of all evil right I mean the
men do this women do this them you're
not masculine enough you know feminine
enough it's a whole other level of
suppression that's happening now where
you know Dogma once again it's just
different Dogma has taken off basically
you're taking away the basic humanity of
people cooperating and loving each other
and being with each other in ways that's
good for all humans so to speak and so
when a man is confused about his role as
a man the more the most important thing
is to consider that anything he does he
does for a woman or in order to be loved
or in order to be approved off he is
holding him hostage it's slavery and so
anything he does so that she's off his
back or she loves him where he gets some
or whatever is enslaving him and hence
he's not free and when he's not free
he's never going to be the man he wants
to be so what I would say to any man who
comes to me and the man you know I teach
men's groups not how to become a better
man but how to be a man with a woman
right because I'm not a man so I can
talk about how to become a better man
but I can talk a lot about how do you
become the man that's compelling to a
woman and the first and foremost thing
is become free right
you have to get to a point where you no
longer give a [ __ ] if your actions are
going to bring you the love and the fame
and the fortune and the desired outcome
that you desire because as long as your
desire driven or outcome driven you are
a [ __ ] to somebody your boss the world
money your woman as long as you
somebody's [ __ ] you're never going to
be free and so freedom that kind of
freedom of no longer needing to be
pleasing mommy which is what it comes
down to we can talk about that a little
bit more later not wanting to not having
to please mommy is the thing that makes
you able to do anything you want to do
with great clarity because you don't
have to do it you might as well you
might still do amazing things for your
woman but you do them because they're a
right thing to do in that particular
moment for that particular occasion not
because if you don't there's hell to pay